Speaker 1: Let's get to the phones which
we do via discord on the Friday show
David Pakman dot com slash discord Join
the discord It's free it's a good time
but let's hear from some people at David Pakman
dot com slash discord see what is on people's
minds. Let's go first to Nelson from bethlehem.
Nelson welcome to The David Pakman Show.
Nelson, welcome to the program.
Speaker 4:
Oh, I apologize, Steve, but I had to talk. And
thank you for taking me first. I actually just
had one question, and I want to know if I could
get your thoughts on some breaking news. Sure.
What is your opinion on the United States
government taking out the mandates today
for the international air travel?
You have to be vaccinated before.
Speaker 1: The U.S. took that out for
incoming travelers from other countries.
Speaker 4: Yes. And federal employees
and the such no longer have to be COVID
vaccinated. I saw that and I was really surprised.
I thought it was supposed to be a promised thing.
I think the White House put out a thing on it. You
can see it. I believe that it all ends on May 11.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Let's see. I've actually got it
here so we can be precise. U.S. COVID 19 travel
restrictions to be lifted. May 11th will be the
last day for multiple restrictions, including that
international air visitors be fully vaccinated.
Listen, I don't know what my medical opinion on
it is. I can tell you that politically, I get why
it's been done, why it is being done. And I also,
you know, if we are to believe that at this point
in time, the vaccine doesn't prevent transmission,
then in a sense, I get it right. It's sort of
if you want to protect yourself from becoming
seriously ill, you get yourself vaccinated. But
if it doesn't reduce transmission, then why does
everybody need to be required to be vaccinated?
I think the risk of it is. In an ideal world,
Nelson, at some point we will have a COVID vaccine
that does prevent transmission. And at that point,
no longer having the tool of requiring it
could be a missed opportunity to actually
reduce transmission of the virus.
But that's a future looking question.
Speaker 4: Yep. Well, I completely agree. David.
Well, thank you for having me on first and
shout out to my good friend soft gentleman. He's
also listening, but he can't call in right now,
so. Okay. David, have a great day.
Speaker 1: Nelson from Bethlehem. Very
powerful stuff. What was that? The soft something.
I don't know what that is. I don't know if that's
a listener of mine. Let's go next to Wil from
North Carolina, Wil from North Carolina. Welcome
to the program. What's on your mind?
Speaker 4: Hello.
Speaker 2: I know that your focus is
largely electoral politics, but I was
wondering if you have any.
Speaker 4: Comment on.
Speaker 2: Some means of effecting progressive
political change outside of electoral ism, like
maybe labor organizing or mutual aid
in your community. Just any thoughts.
Speaker 4: You have on that? Sure.
Speaker 1: I think that if all we're
doing is voting and then tuning out for
four or two years, that is a huge missed
opportunity. And this is unfortunately,
you know, the right understands this. Well,
that's the thing. The right understands we're
going to raise hell at school board meetings
and we're going to try to get involved
in municipal requirements. And, you know,
this recent idea of let's ban trans people from
dressing in line with their gender identity,
that there is the Department of Agriculture, I
guess, in Texas is trying to put that in place.
The right knows how to get involved in all of this
other stuff. And I think it's critically important
that the left do it as well. And whether
it's, again, school board, city councils,
events in communities, all of these things dealing
with police policy. Right. Get making yourself
heard when there is the possibility of changing
police policy within a municipality. We've got to
be doing all of these things. And importantly, you
know, Neil Postman wrote about this, okay, we vote
and then we watch all this news about Russia
and Ukraine. As interesting as it is and as
as important as what's going on in Russia and
Ukraine is in affecting people's lives there.
What are you are you are you going to do
about the situation in Russia, Ukraine? And
shouldn't we redirect some of the time that
we're focused on issues that we will never
impact? Shouldn't we redirect some of that time
on our local communities? So I'm with you 100%.
Speaker 2: All right. Well,
thank you, David. Have a great.
Speaker 1: Day. All right, Will from
North Carolina. Great to hear from you.